Audio is working here we go what what
what you guys realize that I that I
talked to myself for a living I think I
mentioned that before
it's kind of sad hey what's going on
YouTube two videos in a row is this
Christmas no it's not Christmas because
it's hot as [ __ ] where's Captain Planet
when you need a pump with your tight ass
red shorts and your green mole you are
the weirdest looking superhero I've ever
seen and recycle those plastics or else
I'll turn you into a [ __ ] tree
Captain Planet [ __ ] now you guys
every now and then love to send me
articles and if you tweet it to me
enough of course I can't ignore it you
guys haven't heard about the story this
one's a doozy my gut
Ahmed Mohammed a high schooler in Texas
was arrested for supposedly making a
bomb and interrogated by the police
can you guess what skin color is brown
what religion Muslim are we surprised
understand I don't find like this
situation in and of itself funny I find
it hilarious because news like this
constantly pops up and it sounds like a
Comedy Central sketch a man brings in a
school project which turns out that he
made and engineered a [ __ ] clock and
the teacher assumed that he brought a
bomb now even after a met told a teacher
that it was a clock she still didn't
believe him now if you want to think
about the kids background you had to
think what was he a troublemaker was he
a little socially awkward that he gives
signs of being a Kennedy's you cannot
make this [ __ ] up brown skinned Muhammad
Muslim teacher don't you think that
you're supposed to use your brain and be
a little bit more smart if he was a
[ __ ] terrorist would he be the worst
terrorist on earth why the [ __ ] would he
make a bomb and show it to you and say
hey teacher look what I made I'm gonna
blow you the [ __ ] on up hashtag Wars
terrorists on earth now conversely there
might be some of you out there that
might say it wasn't being racially
persecuted that
like a bomb really dude that looked like
a bomb it just had wires what the [ __ ]
was gonna explode is that ratio go find
Tina she's just absolutely ridiculous
it's like every time I meet a white
person that has never met an asian
person the first thing they do is bow
for no [ __ ] reason you always bow you
don't even know that you do it hey how's
it going I'm David nice to meet you
David that's cool
I think the worst part of this situation
is that the school refuses to admit
fault even the school district they're
saying that they went through the right
precautious because it possibly could
have been a bomb but it does beg the
question even though you say it does not
matter if the kid was white with the
capital H right would you have thought
it was the bomb now I don't want to pull
the race card but I'm thinking now I'm
thinking Little Jimmy would've got an
a-plus for going above and beyond for
making that wonderful engineered clock
but when Mohammad brings something in a
silver box suddenly yeah you know what
the funny thing is I think every time
Ahmed speaks they hear something
different that he's actually saying I'm
sorry honey what's your name hi nice to
meet you I'm Ahmed Osama bin Laden no I
said I meant Osama bin Laden Ahmed Osama
bin Laden what the [ __ ] and I just want
to be inside the teachers head just so I
could look through his ocular cavities
and see what the [ __ ] he was looking at
because what he or she should have saw
was but when they saw was I can't wrap
my [ __ ] head around this it's almost
like that Rachel Dolezal thing where she
was pretending she was [ __ ] real now
for those of you out there who aren't
immigrants and we're born in this
country well lucky you but I'm gonna
give you a little quick brush up about
what it's like to be an immigrant you
know that whole cliche saying that you
heard when you were younger that your
parents came to this country to give you
a better life well guess [ __ ] what is
more than just a cliche a lot of that is
[ __ ] true so you come into this
country as an immigrant you had this kid
you want to give him the best education
and everything that this country has to
offer and at the
end of the day you're still a [ __ ]
Brown Muslim terrorist you have any idea
how difficult is to be judge and
persecuted on something that you can't
change something that you haven't done
wrong and no matter what you do no
matter the status that you get to in
life and how high you climb you're
always just that Muslim terrorist
I am super happy that he has been
getting a lot of support from people
like Mark Zuckerberg and of course
President Obama himself
I'm anybody can give you a little bit of
advice I'm not sure if you even care to
see this video but I guarantee you it
will get better you will grow up as a
strong human being that will survive
this small little incident and make
something great out of it because trust
me greatness
always comes out of adversity hey what
is going on YouTube well hope you guys
enjoyed that video once again that was a
suggestion made by multiples of you
guys's so my friends don't be shy I'm
trying to be a little more interactive
with you leave in the comments below
more topics and more articles that you
want me to talk about because the more
that you give me the more that I can
post up I got your back I'm gonna do
this we can do it but now let's get top
hands
so remember new videos every Wednesday
and Sunday make sure y'all check that
out Wednesday and Sundays and guess what
you might get a little lucky if I post a
little extra I think the worst type of
stereotyping that I went through was
that kids constantly looked at me like I
was [ __ ] smart but I got back at them
because I let them copy my homework and
they failed all their [ __ ] classes